so you got your new Apple credit card
and you can't put your Apple credit card
in your wallets or in your pocket or
anywhere that might get scratched so
obviously the next logical thing to do
is to buy a very expensive wallet to put
your Apple card in and of course the
company to do that it make these
absolutely ridiculously expensive but
yet incredibly engineered iPhone cases I
have made videos about these before but
now they have come along and made a
wallet for your Apple credit card is
there anything more Apple than this I
don't even know here it is it comes in
three different variants there's a
titanium there's a stealth and a bold
they're all machined from aerospace
grade titanium mechanically textured
surface finished and the gold one has a
gold PVD coating and do you know how
much the gold one cost
nine hundred and eighty three dollars
the good news is if you have your Apple
credit card and you buy it with Apple
pay you can get two percent cashback
you're already saving money with your
new expensive wallet and expensive
credit card
let's open us up I'm hyped I don't even
know which one they sent me let me put
this in frame it's fun but it kind of
looks like it's rose gold like this
looks like it matches this the carbon
fiber looks so good and it looks like it
has like this little like elastic piece
here so that'll allow you to put more
credit cards in and then just your Apple
credit card and hold on let's try it out
you've got a new home so basically just
gonna carry this around just for my
Apple credit card totally convenient
totally normal very hydrastine thing to
do so here's what it looks like inside
the wallet
it was how crazy this is it's just so
silly so crazy cuz I definitely thought
this had like two sides so it kind of
tricked me but it's just one side how
necessary is this want a scale of one to
ten let's see what else is in here look
at this
screwdriver this is nice let's see
what's in here
Oh a little card what's this this
basically feels like a movie apple
credit card this talks about my warranty
this shows you how to use it pry open
the wallet so it fits all of your cards
access so this shows you how to use a
voice actually directions in case you're
gonna figure it out I don't know you
figured out how to shop online for it so
I think you can figure out how to use
the wallet you know where it is game
with a free screwdriver can you even
believe it so that's it I guess that's
the unboxing I guess my question to you
is what is the most that you would ever
pay for a wallet I mean I feel like I've
definitely bought more expensive wallets
but I don't think I've ever bought
anything like that they have two other
models so there's only 50 of these that
have ever been made and this is good
that can you see it number three
engraved right there so the stealth one
which is like a black matte finish is
seven hundred and thirty seven dollars
and the titanium without engraving is
four hundred and ninety one dollars if
you pull this out of the Apple Store
people are gonna be like wow you're cool
or they're gonna be like why are you
using a credit card here with you could
just use Apple pay looks so good
like at this point in my life like I've
already accepted that I'm crazy obsessed
Apple fan
I do know that this is completely over
the top it's a little unnecessary the
fact that at least I know does that make
it better I'm sure but like you guys so
much for watching this is pretty cool I
am such a huge fan of gray and I think
they've made some really incredible
products in the past and I love like
their engineering like everything just
looks really cool and it looks very
futuristic and I love the material
granite it is very expensive so that is
something that is something that is a
little hard to get past but the fact
that they are really credible and it is
a limited edition type thing this is
something that I've talked about in the
past where it is sort of like a jewelry
factor like you buy necklaces you buy
rings you buy that kind of stuff like
that's kind of what you're buying with
this like you're buying an insane crazy
titanium gold-plated wallet for your
titanium Apple credit card those are
words that I never thought that I would
ever say when I said them and here we
are make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button and click like if you enjoyed
this video and be sure to hit the bell
so you'll be notified when I post new
videos and I've got some other videos
right here I have my most recent video
here and one of my videos here that is
recommended to you guys that Google
thinks that you're gonna like so check
that out I'll see you later I